is that a george st
perriere
that's epic i'm sorry but uh
so why is everything closed man the
world's opening up dude i got my second
vaccination shot
you know like well it's because we're
always behind you guys in canada
i'm from montreal so we're always late
what you guys have we always have it
late
so it sucked but that's how it is
you know i guess we're always a few
months behind you guys okay
so so everything's been locked down for
the whole time yeah they they announced
that it will re
it will open uh june in june but only
the
the outside the patio seating areas
for the restaurant okay that's crazy
quick question if you were after a fight
you get seriously injured would you
rather go to a canadian hospital
or an american hospital oh that's a good
question i'm american
when i when i blew my my two acl
i went to u.s and the reason is yes in
canada the health
system is free the health care system is
accept accessible to everybody
every citizen however they treat
everybody the same so
and a professional athlete for example
my body is my
instrument of work so i would have the
same treatment
as a 70 years old
lady so that's why i went to u.s because
in us you pay for it but you
you can have special treatment in order
to rehab
better and faster okay wow
you know like uh nobody has to pay for
for health care
in canada but you know you get the same
medical care as some [ __ ] [ __ ]
some slow off the street
you know what you wait a very long time
let's say you go to
yeah normally you go you go to it for uh
like something
to the hospital you have to wait for a
very long time so yeah
there are some advantages but there's
some bad
issues with it as well yeah your your
appendix explodes and you're there for
eight hours just right
freaking out hi oh yeah oh yeah
it's it's it's bad yeah that's that
canadian patience
i i love it i
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon and buy stevo's hot sauce for
your
butthole yeah
yeah dude